le beau temps Conrad bientôt à nos
portes et avec lui ça morce sera la
saison du jardinage même si rien égal en
termes de fraîcheur un légume qu'on
cueille directement au potager au-delà
du goût et du plaisir associé à ce pasta
jardinier est-ce que c'est rentable
est-ce que ça vaut tout le temps les
efforts les sous investis un jardinier
de Gatineau s'est posé la question et
ses résultats sont étonnants
[Musique]
je suis menuisier charpentier surtout
charpentier ça se voit peut-être en
regardant les structures que j'ai basées
j'ai un jardin parce que j'aime ça aussi
pas pour sauver de l'argent alors
que vous avez les poils aussi
Laurent Dubois jardine d'abord pour le
plaisir
mais au fil des ans il a réussi à
cultiver dans son jardin et sa petite
sœur domestique pour plus de 90% de ses
besoins annuels en légumes
[Musique]
c'est possible d'être autosuffisant au
Québec en légumes au moins un fruit
aussi mais là on n'est pas encore rendu
là mais c'est mon jardin il y a pas
énorme là c'est pas un champ là c'est
pas un c'est pas une ferme
le champ et la ferme c'est là où tout a
commencé pour Laurent Dubois c'était en
2009 dans l'Ouest canadien il était
alors qu'au gestionnaire d'une ferme
maraîchère c'est de le cultiver pour le
revendre tu es à plus grande échelle la
société maintenant ma première
exposition
[Musique]
dès la première année c'était clair que
ça faisait pas de sens de juste des
défis tes constamment c'est pas rentable
depuis il est venu s'installer dans la
région de Gatineau où il cultive
maintenant pour lui et sa petite famille
il y a beaucoup de passants sur la route
là comme vous pouvez voir puis il y en a
beaucoup qui s'arrête assez beau ce que
vous faites puis mais ça doit être du
travail puis je vous vois travailler
puis vous êtes tout le temps là-dedans
puis oh moi je pourrais jamais faire ça
moi ça m'a commencé à me fâcher un peu
parce que de mon à mon avis à moi si tu
attends partiel à mon avis c'est pas
beaucoup de travail
fait que je me suis dit bon ben je vais
le faire moi-même
c'est en janvier 2021 que le jardinier
se lance dans cette aventure
il note chaque minute de travail investi
pour leur production personnelle de
légumes de la préparation du sol et des
semences en passant par la fertilisation
la récolte jusqu'au stockage des surplus
pour la saison froide
j'estime la distance au magasin où on
voit déjà tu es au marché puis le gaz
que ça coûte très
combien de temps ça m'a pris acheter les
graines ou les faire venir c'est qu'on
mixe là qu'on met que j'ai dépensé en
réparation de quoi que ce soit c'est
chaque minute a été calculé
selon tous ces calculs lui et sa
conjointe aurait consacré au total de
mai à octobre
215 heures à entretenir et à gérer leur
jardin et ses récoltes
la période plus intense du mois d'août
le jardinier évalue à 90 minutes par
jour le temps de travail requis pour
s'acquitter de ses tâches
Laurent Dubois a aussi voulu estimer la
valeur de sa production annuelle de
légumes il sait référé au prix courant
du marché pour l'année de sa récolte
qu'il a évalué après de 6200 dollars
ce chef-là c'est notre valeur après ça
il y a le coût des intrants à chaque
année un investissement à faire c'est
sûr le jardinier a même inclus dans ses
coups de production le montant amorti de
ses investissements en équipements et en
infrastructure une fois que j'ai récolté
toute cette information là toutes les
données
comment
être capable de le quantifier c'est
d'une manière
approchable c'est plus concrète possible
concrète alors je me suis dit le taux
horaire c'est reconnaissable
en tenant compte de tous les paramètres
répertoriés durant l'année dont
l'augmentation du prix des aliments en
épicerie il en est arrivé à une
évaluation monnayable du temps investi
un taux horaire de 50 dollars l'heure ça
m'a surpris j'en étais carrément étonné
avec les résultats que j'ai vu je me
suis dit il faut que je partage ça avec
le monde parce que ils vont rester
étonnés étonné oui mais est-ce réaliste
mon mon travail avec les étudiants c'est
les amener à des gestionnaires agricoles
[Musique]
Sophie Martel est agroéconomiste de
formation elle a analysé en détail le
rapport du jardinier de Gatineau
[Musique]
dans ces coups de production si on veut
si c'est des petites
erreurs mais je trouvais qu'il y avait
une belle rigueur quand même dans la
prise de données il faut le faire il
faut prendre le temps de le faire la
prise de données de temps de ses coûts
qui ont impliqués ça j'ai trouvé ça
intéressant et son exercice il est
correct pour jardinier amateur
sa véritable surprise elle l'a eu en
voyant la conversion en salaire de ces
rendements de jardinage domestiques
je me tends je peux faire 50 dollars de
l'heure et là je fais oh ok selon ce
film Martel ses calculs ne tiennent pas
compte de la grande disponibilité que
requiert l'entretien d'un potager comme
celui de Laurent Dubois
45 minutes par jour et c'est pas
beaucoup c'est vrai 45 minutes par jour
dans ces temps de roche mais c'est un 45
minutes non consécutif c'est un 45
minutes il faut être là à des moments
précis
donc faut être proche puis être là au
moment où c'est important pour les
insectes pour l'irrigation pour tout
sortir j'ai souvent dit que j'étais
capable de transformer un investissement
de 1$ en 5 dollars de légumes puis là si
je me fie aux analyses comme monsieur
Dubois nous propose lui on était dans un
ratio d'à peu près 1 pour 6 ans il était
passé Pierre-Antoine Gilbert et le
collègue de Sophie Martel le rapport de
Laurent Dubois la conforter dans ses
propres estimations pour ce qui est du
jardinage domestique j'ai à peu près les
mêmes dimensions de jardin à la maison
je produis à peu près les mêmes légumes
j'ai souvent dit que ça prenait
peut-être 10 heures au printemps
implanté le jardin 5 heures par semaine
durant l'été pour l'entretenir mais oui
ça ça se tient
[Musique]
figure confirme une tendance bien réelle
celle du jardinage domestique raisonné
merci de le faire de façon performante
de professionnaliser un peu le jardinage
pour atteindre des résultats
dans la sélection des aliments qu'on
plante c'est des patates en magasin ça
coûte rien c'est du maïs ça coûte rien
fait c'est beaucoup moins rentable que
de planter des tomates des concombres
c'est des lait dessus c'est en magasin
concombre anglais c'est 5 pièces le
concombre la betterave qui est déformée
ou trop petite bah lui il va la
consommer c'est beau là
tout ce que un producteur pourrait
peut-être pas capable de vendre
j'irai pas jusqu'à dire placement
garanti parce que c'est pas tout le
monde qui est bon pour cultiver non plus
tu il faut prendre le temps de récolter
s'informer c'est pas tout le monde que
le pouce vert
la passion du jardinage ça reste un
plaisir de le faire qu'est-ce qui te
plaît étonné toi en fait c'est d'avoir
pris le temps de comptabiliser toutes
les heures de travail qui sont investis
l'agriculture on a beaucoup de documents
de référence économiques sur lesquels on
peut se baser pour avoir une idée du
temps de travail mais au niveau de
jardin domestique je l'avais pas vu et
moi c'est la première fois je vois
quelqu'un qui chiffre tout qui prend le
temps de le faire il doit être passionné
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'on fait quelque chose
on rentre à la maison on l'écrit tout de
suite
pour n'importe qui qui veut avoir un
jardin à n'importe quel échelle ceux qui
se disaient ben tu m'as demandé si ça
vaut la peine ben oui ça vaut la peine
[Musique]